a gymnast would always
notice if a screw or nail were
on the beam because you're pretty much
always spotting where your hands and
feet are
hi everyone i'm caitlin ohashi a
four-time national team member and
a former ucla gymnast so i just started
my own youtube channel so you guys can
check me out there
today i'm going to be watching
gymnastics movie clips and rating them
on their accuracy
i like that they added not only like
flipping skills but connecting skills
because you need both for
uh gymnastics so she did a round off
back handspring
two and a half punch front full i used
to do that skill in my routine as well
the leaps are not necessarily what you
would see
i've always thought the kicking parts
were like funny to me
typically if you're an elite gymnast
you're so tired
that you don't even have time to add
those things
i do a double lay like that we both have
that part in common for
sure in 2006 i feel like gymnasts were
more robotic than this movie portrayed
which is super awesome so
this type of routine is way more
accepted now than it used to be
[Music]
i don't think i've ever seen anyone do
that in gymnastics
but it's incredible it would be super
fun
the dance moves are way way different
than something you would see on beam
this is reality i don't know if i've
ever seen someone do
a back handspring double back just
because there's not a lot of momentum
out of a step out back handspring this
was um
definitely less realistic gymnastics
wise as well
besides the dance just because it was
like she definitely didn't have all the
requirements in there
she didn't have a leap pass or turn
unless you want to count the head spin
cause i would i would say she would just
need
more dance elements even though she was
dancing the whole time
but specific dance elements so i would
give the first one
a 10 out of 10 and the second one
probably a three out of ten
okay so i've never cheered before so
what front hand springs step out round
off back handspring step out round off
back handspring full
twisting layout every gymnast would
probably be able to do that
but it's not anything our coaches would
ever
ask us to do
she started out with like a cartwheel
and then she turned around
and did like a front handspring we never
have cartwheels in our tumbling passes
it'll be roundoffs which is the closest
thing to that you typically will
turn when you're in the air or
not on your feet also she only took like
two steps into that which i understand
some of her skills built momentum
but we do a little more than two steps
probably
at least three or four it's a lot harder
on a hardwood floor
because we do have a little padding and
a little bit of a spring
props to cheerleaders because they do a
lot of stuff that i'm like
i have no idea how they did it so for an
accurate gymnastics pass
that would probably be a zero
[Music]
amazing so that was rhythmic gymnastics
and not artistic gymnastics not too
knowledgeable on rhythmic gymnastics but
obviously it's always on the floor
they're
incredibly flexible they are like
coordinated
which most gymnast artistic gymnasts are
not coordinated
so they take that ribbon and they throw
it up
they do something like beautiful and
then they catch it again
you know he was getting pretty good
spins on his
ribbon but since rhythmic gymnastics
is so beautiful and like stunning
he didn't like elongate his legs at all
and he wasn't showing any um flexibility
he was like galloping versus actually
like
doing something
i've never seen a gymnast smoking in on
the
on the rings women don't do rings as an
apparatus
that's a men's event and
typically you would see them like
straight out he was kind of down here
which would be even harder
to hold like just thinking about it i'm
like oh his shoulders are torn
like and it's just everything iron cross
is
nearer to impossible unless you're like
that trained in it
i would rate that as probably is
zero
a gymnast would always notice if a screw
or nail were on the beam because you're
pretty much
always spotting where your hands and
feet are and you're
also just like looking at the beam
here we go candace stay loose
that girl on bars was doing a lot of
giants and she needed to come off the
bar a lot sooner than that anyway
[Laughter]
the form of the giants were fine she did
a little blind change in there
also i think that if a lot of chalk is
coming into your face
you would be able to like close your
eyes
and like stop the momentum of your giant
and just kind of like
jump off after instead of doing the
whole extra like peeling thing
i think that it's goofy for the most
part
but it's more common than you'd think
like a lot of people we call it scorpion
so like
i've i've ended up like that a couple
times
from that height of the bar and it looks
painful
and it is painful so this is obviously a
little bit exaggerated but gymnastics is
definitely a very dangerous spore and i
know
of people that have actually lost their
lives to the sport and so
it's something that you can't really let
your mind get loose in no matter how
comfortable you
are with a skill or how long you've been
doing it granted we learned how to fall
from a young age
so a lot of our falls are safer but
you can still get into stuff you didn't
expect
what she was doing on bars you it's not
that hard
to stop your momentum she should have
been
a little more prepared to stop them
i would give the gymnastics a 10.
obviously i think that fall is very
realistic
in gymnastics but how it happened is
not realistic oh boy
i would say it was a little bit more
like cheerleading back handsprings
which there's a very clear difference
between like a cheerleader
and gymnast cheerleaders have more bent
knees and like spiderman definitely had
more bent knees he was like lower to the
ground when he landed
gymnastics is very technical so if we
were to have bet knees in our back
handsprings we would get deductions he
was just trying to do the back
springs and get out of the way which i
totally understand it reminds me of
this one girl danisha francis who used
to go to ucla but she
was about to fall out of one of her
tumbling passes
and instead of like stepping or falling
she decided to do
a back handspring and it kind of looked
like spider-man's
i've always thought about like what
would i do in a fight like would i be
able to do throw out some gymnastics
moves and like somehow hit them or
not so i don't know if anything would
really be that helpful maybe being able
to kick high
because i'm short so i need to like i
need all the height i can get
we'll say an 8 we'll say an 8.25 seconds
will trigger the alarm
[Music]
she did an arabian that's what she did
when she turned and you would want to
land completely facing backwards and
then turn in the air and do
a front flip to her little handstand
thing she did
she got a good height on it i think her
form was pretty good
yeah everything looked really clean her
knees were straight
it looked like she had momentum on her
back handsprings for the most part
and she did enough to like build that
momentum to be able to get that height
for the arabian
we used to have to hold handstands for a
minute
without moving i'm sure more people
could do it longer than that
especially if you're walking you can
hold it for a long time but
minimum a minute i would rate this in
nine
she was actually pretty good at
gymnastics
that actually reminded me of gymnastics
in the 70s
because we used to have bars that were
way closer together so you would like
hit your hips on the bar that's how
close they were i'm
very grateful for the change because i
feel like they definitely
always walked around with bruises on
their hips and like
their pelvic bones but gymnastics also
got more difficult when they spread the
bars
out wider because then you were able to
do more skills
release moves certain stuff like that
i've kicked my coach on bars
and i also know of just people getting
injured all the time from like walking
underneath could it kick over a dinosaur
if you had the intentions maybe that was
a metal bar right
and those don't give as much but like
ours is wood you don't use your muscles
on bars
except for like holding like your
forearms and stuff like that like you
want to use
the bar as much to your own like
um benefit as you can gymnastically
since it came out in the 97s i'll rate
it
a seven
i don't think the leaps weren't that
good you know some gymnasts don't have
great leaps
technically for choreography there
aren't points
but i think it only helps if you can
like take
the judge out of their like head so much
and want to just watch you
so they're not constantly just writing
down deductions focus
two flips with a full twist push off
right leg
momentum through the round off
what i actually really enjoy about that
movie is that
it goes into her thought process when
she's about to tumble
and i think that as most gymnasts have
cues that they give themselves every
single time that they go
and so she hers was like push off your
back leg strong
certain stuff like that so it's these
little reminders
that just help us you know get through
the past and stay focused
so i actually think that i've competed
in that leo some leotards that i was
wearing
they the elastic would be worn out and
that's when we'd have to
you know get the like spray uh
and use it to stick our leos down
we'll give it we'll give it a 10. i know
i'm not biased or anything
[Music]
she definitely had leg separation on her
pack to the low bar she also if you want
to get really technical
she didn't hit her handstands the bars
were
much closer in the 70s than that clip
showed
for the 70s i would say that was very
like
accurate for the skill level besides
like the bars being a different
length away from each other
[Music]
that isn't that common to see that
dismount but it does still exist today
it's just pretty rare and you would see
it more
through that period but everything was
kind of the same
like all those skills you still see
today she definitely had
deductions within her routine when she
landed
she obviously stumbled around and she
did have a release move
but you'll see like multiple release
moves and spinning moves if you're
trying to go to
the olympics
i'm giving that a 10 for accuracy just
because of the way the coach responded
[Laughter]
it's funny because that was in russia
and i had russian coaches
and i would say russian coaches tend to
be pretty brutal
and a lot of coaches are so if we just
look at each other we're like oh yeah
our coach is rushing we're like
we understand exactly how training was
then
i thought it was a 10 because you still
see all of those skills today
so she does the hands her feet go over
and then she does an extra flip
and lands back on her feet that first
one is very accurate
so in college we would have we would
have a natty stick and a college stick
the college stick is more of like acting
like you stuck it like if you know
you're gonna step
it's like stepping and just saluting to
the judges immediately and that's like
more of a college stick
whereas a natty stick is being able to
hold it
put your feet together salute and then
turn and salute the judges
i have no idea what that second vault
was because it
didn't even look like she flipped in it
like it just looked like she was
twisting
and so i like flinched because i'm like
wait a minute is she supposed to
now do a flip the second one
it would probably be like worth nothing
she didn't flip that's actually
based on a true story cary scruggs
who went to the olympics and broke her
foot
she had to go again and she stuck on one
leg
so my freshman year i i was competing be
on beam
i finished the routine but when i did my
dismount my foot slipped off and i
landed on my head
what i didn't know was i fractured my
sternum i'm getting tested for a
concussion and they told me that there
was
equipment malfunction so i got to go
again and i remember doing like
a skill on the floor before i went again
and i was like oh wow like my chest
really hurts
but i still did the full beam routine
did the dismount again
got home found out that i had fractured
my sternum
[Laughter]
so i would rate the first clip a 10
and then the second clip i'll rate it a
four i feel like i'm definitely doing
really bad on these ratings i'm like
going up
but this is how it goes so in gymnastics
too
the later you go and line up the higher
score you're probably going to get